Be comedians are happy,
right?
But everyone doesn't
aspire to be a comedian.
Then you don't watch comedy all the time,
even though you could laugh nonstop more
or less if the comedians funny you want
to get your teeth into something.
And also seems to me that this is one
of the reasons I liked existential
philosophy was that,
you know,
the existentialists believed it's
sort of an original sin idea.
They believe that we came into the world
with an ethical burden already laid in
upon us.
Something like something like that.
And that we had a felt sense that it was
necessary for us to justify our being.
And if we didn't do that,
then we weren't authentic to ourselves.
We weren't moving towards individuality,
we weren't sustaining the community,
we weren't living properly
and that and that,
that idea was deeply embedded in people
as part of their ordinary experience.
And that also seems to me to be accurate.
And you know,
I've dealt with lots of people
say in my clinical practice and
they don't really cut.
They have,
they will come and say,
I wish I wasn't so unhappy.
But they don't usually come and say,
I wish I was happier.
And those things aren't the same.
And then when,
when,
when you talk to people
who are having trouble,
you know,
they want to straighten things out
and figure out how to do them right.
It's something like that.
And,
and that,
that's the primary,
that's their primary goal.
And.